au départ vous verrez que vraiment il ya
une tombe provisions expérimenté dans le
fruit
maintenant la famille tôt qu on a été
privés d'électricité pendant plus de
trois jours lors des pannes qui ont
touché des centaines de milliers de
québécois au début du mois ils ont par
conséquent perdu toutes leurs provisions
et ça a creusé un trou dans leur budget
déjà serré c'est tout là nous ont
beaucoup plus causer du tort parce que
nous avons su des dépenses inattendues
alors c'est vraiment paix dans l'oise le
couple et leurs cinq enfants vivent au
québec depuis huit ans pedro est de
retour sur les bancs d'école et sa femme
travaille de nuit pour 13 $ de l'heure
avec un revenu déjà faible la perte de
leurs réserves est venue compliquer la
donne pour la première fois la famille a
dû se tourner vers une banque
alimentaire ont fini 12e fonds pour
pouvoir soutenir nos propres besoins
mais quand ce soir si cela est arrivé
n'avons plus d'autre choix que de nous
tourner vers l'or le ministre de la
solidarité sociale jean boulet a bien
annoncé il ya quelques jours une aide
spéciale en cas de pertes de denrées
alimentaires
suite aux pannes prolonger mais seuls
les bénéficiaires de l'aide sociale
peuvent la réclamer une erreur selon la
directrice générale des banques
alimentaires du québec
elle aurait dû être plus large et on est
en mesure nous d'identifier les
personnes et les familles qui sont les
plus à risque dans le réseau des banques
alimentaires
alors avec des paramètres clairs avec
des informations claires on aurait pu
identifier les personnes qui sont
vraiment situation de besoin immédiat
anigo vain déplore aussi que son
organisation n'est pas été contacté pour
relayer l'information concernant ce
mesures d'urgence cette mesure leur ai
bénéficié d'une information communiquer
rapidement à tout le réseau des banques
alimentaires parce que c'est maintenant
que ces femmes ils en ont besoin de ce
soutien financier
même s'il ne bénéficie pas de cette aide
pedro et sa famille ne se décourage pas
on est optimiste je pense que on va
toujours continuer à travailler dur si
les gens qui veulent bien nous aider
entre ce sera une très très bonne chose
ici fanny bussières mais nicole
radio-canada laval